hello i'm gav i'm dan we're the slo-mo
guys a while ago we made a video where
we filmed gallium in slo-mo a very
interesting element looks like a
mirrored liquid very similar to mercury
except it won't kill you when you touch
it or breathe near it that's very useful
actually yeah it's such a weird material
isn't it it's uh it melts at hand
temperature yeah so it melts about 30
degrees celsius and that's about 85
degrees orange since i've been standing
here this was solid but it's been in my
hand it's
turning to liquid slowly i thought we
could put a load of it in a blender
put the camera on the robot with this
probe lens and drop it in so that as the
the gallium dips down in the middle we
end up inside a swirling
liquid mirror
there's one thing that i see a problem
with there yeah um gallium actually eats
metal yeah right doesn't it like just
annihilate aluminium yeah eats into
aluminium i think it forms some sort of
alloy that makes the aluminium crumble
to pieces and it's stained glass as well
and unfortunately
this is an aluminium lens with a glass
front obviously so this is
potentially going to be very hazardous
for this lens if any of it gets on it
not very sensible then is it yeah also i
think it eats steel eventually and the
blend is made of steel so we're on a
clock to make this video before start
blending and nothing happens all right
dan while you've been heating the
gallium i've come up with this i see
you've been busy at work
what i like about it is you've got you
know professional grade lighting three
lights
a commercial grade robot holding a 4k
vo phantom yeah you know and some
masking tape and a bag
well in all honesty i'm not sure which
parts of this setup are made from
aluminium so uh we've put the robot in a
dress the camera in a bag and taped the
lens up and as you can see in one of our
tests here some gallium has already got
on there okay so this is where the
blender full of gallium will go
and i've programmed a move
a pretty simple move it just comes
straight down into the space where the
gallium used to be because of the vortex
hopefully that'll be a little bit lower
than where it starts it's going to do a
focus pull on the surface as it comes
down
and then because the vortex will have
sunken the gallium in i'm going to do a
second focus pull to move down so you
start you start sort of looking further
into it
then i'm just going to pull the camera
back out just in case it starts getting
splashed so uh the final move is more of
a safety move but it'll be usable
footage as well
pretty sweet
you know in theory careful not to trip
here that would be an absolute disaster
just
yeah and then clock slightly
clock oh sorry okay go
sorry
got my eyes
so bright i'm like
do you want a slightly different choice
of language
poopoo
poopoo
oh here we go into the goop
it's weird when there's almost
there's like big areas of reflection and
then it goes almost
there's so many reflections that it
doesn't look reflective almost yeah it's
like gloss matte oh there it like it it
seems to vibrate and and do that on and
off doesn't it look it's a really shiny
bit
wow it looks like we're just in it it's
like how is it not on the lens
oh
that was a fat [ __ ] there's some
moments in it look at there was like a
whole bit diving into another one it
looks like you're going through some
sort of like space vortex in a multi
like a metallic
universe yeah
highly recommended to not drink this
smoothie
oh i really like that i'm glad it came
back out because it's a little bit too
much there yeah like i was getting
sucked in i was like yeah
i wonder how long it would have to be
able to watch it without getting a
headache you can actually tell in the
highlights which light is which like the
reddish
tint you've got some like a little bit
of aberration the red ones are the big
lights and the greenish tint is the uh
the nightcore that's interesting and
because of the reflections it's just
everywhere yeah
uh
i think let's do it again maybe a bit of
a 90 degree shirt all right wow all
right
easy b red light red light sorry
all right i'm gonna count you down
wait wait
good call
three two one go
[Music]
all right
flip
how are we looking up there goggly
[Music]
oh it's just amazing how close it gets
to the lens on all sides without caking
the lens and so i just love this lens so
much i think it's my favorite lens that
we use
just allows us to get like slightly
unique footage yeah
so wow in it
oh that was a cool bit that was a bit
that flung out some gallium did you see
that we got like a perfect in-focus look
at why it gets sent sometimes do you
know the flag of the isle of man
[Laughter]
you know what i mean right i might be
chatting absolute rubbish here yeah but
i think it's like these weird like bent
these three bent legs
didn't expect their reaction when i
asked you no i just didn't have any uh
idea okay for this one we're going to
use an even brighter light
it's uh this bright
oh
100 000 lumens
and there that way
[Applause]
and that way i can stop this probe lens
down all the way to f44
okay stand clear here we go
cut oh
make sure that didn't go on anything
metal no it didn't it just flopped onto
the background in the table but that was
a that was a chunky flop
the extra light here allows us to get
more depth of field which means we're in
focus deeper into the vortex oh
looks like a damn
time hole doesn't it like half expecting
a tiny little tardis to come sailing
through we should just get a little
keyring and just lob it in
not an aluminium one no
okay we're going to run a very similar
move we've now got the camera end
mounted
so
the robot's holding the camera
from the back
and doing that will allow us to add
a roll so we're going to do a complete
360 rotation so it's going to
spiral down
into the blender and hopefully not
take it out
ready yep
[Music]
manually get it out there
oh that's really weird now
because you've started your move and
it's wobbling so we're going in look at
that bottom there the bottom is spinning
faster
than the oh look at that like middle bit
come up the bottom is spinning faster
than the top obviously and you can see
it all the way down it's like it speeds
up the further down you get yeah makes
it look really weird
yeah i feel like we're just absolutely
wrecking this guy hang on a second
i'm just getting dizzy hold on
are you going to throw up yeah
oh my goodness i think it's become
un-mirrory it's like frothed up we've
basically
foamed it up is what's happened we've
foamed the galley we've cappuccinoed it
yeah we've made a gallium cappuccino
what we've got off this probe lens yep
because it's a very dark lens when on a
much faster lens and got
colored lights involved
oh turn off the big boys turn off the
big boys try and get an exposure
and we won't be able to go in as deep
but i think the color reflecting off all
different parts would look amazing
i agree yeah
all right well after some time and a lot
of setting up we uh potentially have the
most elaborate lighting setup for a
blender full of gallium in history so
yeah it's a nice blend of light okay
i've just changed the auto exposure so
now we can see the colors these are
titan tubes i'm basically doing the
whole color wheel around the gallium
which gives an incredibly
psychedelic effect on the inside look at
that
that is madness you almost just don't
know what you're looking at yeah it
looks completely wild doesn't it yeah
it's gonna be quite an operation really
i've gotta start the blender
gotta put a cover on it remove the cover
pick the lights up go in
with my colors you've got to start the
robot you've programmed to do your move
yep then you've got to run in with your
colors with a little second delay or so
yeah and then we've got to hold them
like this they're pretty heavy while the
robot goes up and down and the gallium
is blended it's a absolute operation
[Laughter]
i hope it's worth it i hope the footage
is good we've also changed lens there's
no way these lights are bright enough
for the probe so we're now on a much
faster lens right there oh even the lens
looks cool look at that you can see you
can see all the reflection of the lights
i know we're still somehow a thousand
frames a second obviously we can't go in
as far yeah you've just changed lens and
it's made it
so much different hasn't it
ready
go
that was it did it
oh jesus
wow
oh my god
getting like our make from lifting these
things up you were rapid there
i was in there weren't there you were
wrapping
oh
i didn't think it was possible for it to
be more psychedelic
right
what you've done there
oh man is create like a trip
basically look at it that is
madness
it's delectable and gnarly at the same
time
you know when when heimdall whips the
bifrost open
yeah
yeah
you got like the oranges and the stuff
on the on this side and you've got the
blues on that side
your color wheel worked pretty well this
is actually really interesting because
the oxidization of the gallium is
causing a more matte finish the light is
bouncing off that differently to how
it's bouncing off the still very molten
silvery finish so we're almost getting
two reflections of two different colors
in the same area of the galleon
oh look at the best
the mess is differently colored as well
oh yeah
you can see that all the
this is the blue light oh wow rainbow
peas oh look there you go
all the pieces that are flying out now
are getting like multi-colored bits all
over yeah oh that's amazing
this shot was actually one of our test
shots that at the time i didn't think
was any good until i just put it in the
edit and did a color grade on it and
it's actually quite good though the
gallium was still very runny and shiny
and i'd taken the frame rate down on the
camera from a thousand to 250 and
completely opened up on the shutter just
to get as much light in as possible but
i think it turned out really well dan's
holding the red and blue lights and i
eventually make it in there with a green
and this combination of colors just
reminds me of
oil on a road would have been good for
the opening titles of the world is not
enough or something
that is so cool looking isn't it it
looks it looks awesome it looks like the
t-1000
sneezed in a nightclub
[Laughter]
terminator just flung pepper at the
t-1000 and then
his weakness
well i love that it was great i mean it
was a hell of a complicated set to film
what was essentially just a blender yeah
i feel like back in the old days we
would have just
filmed a blender oh yeah the blender
would have been on a bin it would have
been on a ladder leaning in a string
yeah exactly yeah it was quite an overly
engineered complex setup but i think it
really was worth it because without this
lens we wouldn't have been able to get
all the way in and we would want to pull
focus on you know like a couple of mil
away yeah and that was what made it i
think it was also really cool how the
robot could focus all the way down and
like change focus like and perfectly
straight you'd have never been able to
do that no offense i definitely wouldn't
i mean we tried with the sugar cube
didn't we
yeah yeah
one oh do one no two what
it's hot in my shoe
everything's hot and i was like we need
motion control
now we've got it
well hopefully you enjoyed that
mesmerizing footage i think that would
have looked quite good on a tv
yeah if you did fall over while you're
watching it like i almost did
we'll be able to tell especially if
you're using your phone because it
should be a jumbled garbage of letters
you just looking at your phone
all right well hopefully you enjoyed it
make sure you subscribe if you like
slow-mo we've got a second channel we've
got some t-shirts also comes gallium
free we sell them without the gallium on
and we also have some other videos that
you can watch because we've been doing
this for way too long here's one
see you next time